this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video
welcome to the David Pakman show
I of course you know by now this voice
is not that of David Pakman I'm Benjamin
Dixon filling in for David who is a way
for today he will be back tomorrow let's
jump right into the news Brett Kavanaugh
well according to his college friends
he's a liar several friends have come
out to state that Cavanaugh's testimony
before the Senate was untruthful and
some have outright said that he has lied
this comes on the hills of The New York
Times report that says that as an
undergraduate student at Yale Cavanaugh
got into a bar fight all right in
instigated a bar fight I want to start
there let's read the quote from the New
York Times and this is what they had to
say they said quote as an undergraduate
student at Yale Brett Kavanaugh was
involved in an altercation at a local
bar doing which he was accused of
throwing ice on another patron according
to a police report the incident which
occurred in September of 1985 during mr.
Cavanaugh junior year resulted in mr.
Cavanaugh and four other men being
questioned by the New Haven Police
Department mr. Cavanaugh was not
arrested but the police report stated
that a 21 year old man accused mr.
Cavanaugh of throwing ice on him for
some unknown reason the fact that he may
have been that he was drinking right I
think everyone pretty much can conclude
that that's not a big deal drinking is
not a big deal whatsoever the fact that
he may have had an ape roblem with
alcohol in in and of itself was not a
disqualifying trait we don't we don't
vilify somebody just because they have a
problem with alcoholism but as his
friend said on he made at one of his
college friends made a statement
yesterday that I think was appropriate
now the clip that I have doesn't include
this portion but as he begins to say his
experience with Brett Kavanaugh he said
something that was very profound he says
that someone's mistakes at 18 and 21
should not disqualify them for the
their life he said but however as a 53
53 year old federal judge the fact that
he's lying now should disqualify him and
he should face the ramifications taste
take a listen to one of Brett's college
friends saying that Brett is a liar I
have direct repeated knowledge about
Brett's drinking disposition while drunk
and I do believe that Brett's actions as
a 53 year old federal judge matter if he
lied about his past actions on national
television and more especially while
speaking under oath in front of the
United States Senate I believe those
lies should have consequences it is
truth that is at stake and I believe
that the ability to speak the truth even
when it does not reflect well upon
oneself is a paramount quality we seek
in our nation's most powerful judges I
can unequivocally say that in denying
the possibility that he ever blacked out
from drinking and in downplaying the
degree and frequency of his drinking
brett has not told the truth so he has
repeated knowledge I mean that the last
sentence is the most profound he said
Brett has not told you the truth that's
one thing but according to this brett
has perjured Cavanaugh has perjured
himself before the Senate in a sworn
testimony before the Senate now the
whole picture of Brett Kavanaugh is
starting to to reveal itself to us it's
revealing itself to us and we can see
that the person who had the meltdown in
the testimony last week is exactly the
person that all of his college friends
are describing he is the person who
would start a bar fight by losing his
temper losing his cool and throwing ice
on somebody who says that for some
unknown reason he didn't know why Brett
did it but just for some unknown reason
this is the type of person that the
Republicans are trying to put on the
Supreme Court but it gets worse here's
another clip from two other college
friends from Brett Kavanaugh past this
time they were on the last word with
lawrence O'Donnell and this is what they
had to say
I was appalled he was clearly lying and
it was incredibly disturbing to see
somebody perjuring themselves who's in
line to be a Supreme Court justice and
Lynne Brooks your reaction to what you
heard I agreed the reason that I decided
to speak out was when he gave the Fox
News interview and as I said in the
Washington Post tried to paint him as a
self as a choirboy where he all he did
was study and play sports and every once
in a while he would have a beer and
that's simply not consistent with the
Brett Kavanaugh that I knew in college
and that was Liz Swisher and Lynne
Brooks Lynne Brooks actually gave a
statement to the FBI about her
experiences with Brett Kavanaugh and she
stands by that statement still today
here's one more piece of evidence from
Brett Kat from Brett's past from a
college friend that is extremely
extremely damning there's a tweet on
Twitter by Jamie Roche who was Brett
Kavanaugh his college roommate and this
is what Jamie had to say he said quote
as Brett Kavanaugh was college freshman
roommate
I was never contacted by the FBI for any
of their background checks I assumed
college behavior was not a topic of
interest they did not find Debbie story
because they were not looking for it who
was Debbie you might ask debbie is
actually Debra Ramirez and she is the
woman the 53 year old woman former
college roommate I'm sorry not roommate
but college classmate with Brett
Kavanaugh who according to a story in
The New Yorker by Ronan Farrow who
actually let me read the quote from
Ronan Farrow and Jane Mayer this is what
they said about Ramirez they said quote
Ramirez said that she felt confident
enough in her recollections to say that
she remembers Kavanagh had exposed
himself at a drunken dunk dormitory
party thrust his penis in her face and
caused her to touch it without her
consent as she pushed him away
Ramirez is now calling for the FBI to
investigate
Cavanaugh's role in the NCAA
I would think an FBI investigation would
be warranted now this is a problem for
bread and this is a problem for Brett
because Republicans as a handful of
Republicans really just won Jeff Flake
has called for this investigation and in
the midst of the calling of this
investigation you would remember from
David's clip yesterday he was discussing
how this investigation is a farce and it
is a farce and so much as the White
House attempted to limit the scope of
this investigation to a small a very
narrow focused very myopic focus that
could have helped Brett to still get
away with it but now we have a bigger
problem because Jeff Flake along with I
believe one other Republican has
pressured the White House to open up the
scope of the investigation and the White
House has acquiesced and now the FBI has
the Liberty to investigate all facets of
these of these claims including that of
Debbie Ramirez including that of dr.
Ford that we heard from heard from on
last week and so now we're getting ready
to get a deep dive into the real
personality of Brett Kavanaugh here's
why this is his real personality it's
not that you can't change from who you
were in college which unto into becoming
a better person which is very difficult
to do but it's possible it's not that we
should hold people individuals to who
they were at 16 17 and 18
even though society still does that
particularly with minorities I mean our
entire lives are ended at the age of 17
because of decisions that we made matter
of fact before I even finish my sentence
if you or I had carried ourselves like
Brett Kavanaugh in college and you are
either a minority or you come from the
working class and you did not have the
the privilege of having money to guide
you through life we would have been we
would have been arrested none of us
would be up for consideration for
anything if we carried ourselves in the
manner in which all of Brett's college
roommates say he carried himself and
it's not because
you don't you should not get an
opportunity to grow into something more
it's that it's very rare that you have
people given that opportunity unless you
are a wealthy particularly white
individual and specifically a man I mean
there's an entire there's an entire
exelon of society that has lived without
ramifications their entire lives
they aren't above the law they don't
have to worry about these little these
these these laws I mean there's another
story coming up where a a man who man
who was facing 11 years in jail for 44
pounds of marijuana it's only getting
probation you know so that people with
connections either you're wealthy in
terms of just raw money or you're
wealthy in terms of connections they
have been able to get away with stuff
throughout American history and so the
problem isn't that somebody who's young
and makes a mistake and has had an
opportunity to grow out of it the
problem is really that we're seeing a
guy who's never been held accountable
for anything and you could tell that by
his demeanor and its lack of not even
just decorum but he could not comport
himself in a in a dignified manner or
manner he not even in a decent manner in
that investigation or in the hearing
last week he really had a meltdown a
genuine bona fide meltdown and he looked
like a person who has never been held
accountable in his life and because of
that it's not his mistakes when he was
19 it's his mistakes at 53 that show us
he has not grown a bit since he was 19